here with reaction ohio congressman jim
jordan along with outkick founder clay
travis uh congressman jordan take a bow
sir you helped get rid of the ministry
of truth um thank you for doing that uh
bad idea but
uh we'll work together on it as kamala
says
well sean here's what i wonder what
would the disinformation governance
board have fact check the democrat
witness today who came in front of our
committee and said men can get pregnant
and have an abortion i mean we'll never
know sean i'm almost saddened by this
because i wish they would have maybe
waited a day before they disbanded this
board so we could see exactly what nina
jankowicz would have said to that
ridiculous statement made in the
judiciary committee today by the
democrat witness so thank you for the
work you've done in helping get rid of
this
governance board and of course the work
clay has done on his radio station is
our radio show as well
yeah and clay
i think what we're really getting down
to and my former colleague i always like
carl cameron actually thinks we ought to
be putting people maybe in jail for
disinformation i'm like i don't know
what happened to carl it's not the guy
that i knew when he worked here but um
it's getting crazy but i really believe
the target
of this is always going to be
conservatives liberals are never called
out three years lying conspiracy
theories about trump russia collusion
that never happened uh never mind what
happened to nicholas sandman never mind
all the other cases that they were wrong
in from richard jewell to cambridge
police to ferguson to to baltimore and
freddie gray uh duke lacrosse uva they
get it all wrong all the time and
they're never held accountable and they
never retract their remarks apologize
and make a correction ever
you're right sean and i want to thank
the congressman i saw that clip and my
jaw dropped and i know there's a lot of
people who work in media that watch your
show sean and i think we have to start
asking all democrats can men get
pregnant and can they have abortions
because i thought that was a pretty
settled fact and we got democrats under
oath in front of the congressman here
saying that men can in fact get pregnant
and have abortion so you don't want to
go back i don't think that doesn't i'm
gonna let you pick up your thoughts
minister of truth
let me just play it because i don't
think people have seen this enough
yes what do you say a woman is
i believe that everyone can identify for
themselves
okay
um
do you believe then that men can become
pregnant and have abortions
yes
there you go clay
i'm learning something new every day
if people had not seen this
it is so unbelievable what is going on
think about this for a minute sean and
also jim i mean we've got jeff bezos who
runs the washington post now feuding
with joe biden because of how
incompetent they are on economic policy
earlier this afternoon elon musk came
out and said i'm leaving behind the
democrat party because they are totally
losing their minds and i think we're
starting to stack some wins sean and
congressman think about this cnn plus
collapses the ministry of truth didn't
even last as long as cnn plus did you've
got elon musk buying twitter and if you
look at the data on some of these
primaries georgia pennsylvania north
carolina republican voters are coming
out and they are energized and they are
excited and it is because they are
fighting against insanity there are two
parties right now the insane party which
is the democrats and the same party
which is the republicans
87 jim jordan of the vote the top three
vote getters they all claim to be maga
candidates in pennsylvania i mean
amazing then you add look at trump's
record depending on whether you think
his comments were an endorsement of
madison court cloth on he's either 81 or
and three or 81 and two meaning 81
victories right and what elon musk said
is in the past i voted democrat because
they were mostly the kindness party he
wrote but they have become a party of
division and hate so i can no longer
support them and will vote republican
now watch the dirty tricks campaign
against me unfold he's right about all
points
no exactly but look the the trump
endorsements the most powerful political
endorsement in american history without
a doubt we understand that the country
has common sense as clay point out
republican party is the party of common
sense and regular people democrat party
is the party of craziness there's a
reason 7 out of 10 of our fellow
citizens think the country's on the
wrong track in my time in politics i
don't know if i've ever seen wrong track
numbers that bad and that's because
america has common sense and they
understand that
jerry nadler the chairman of the
judiciary committee had to approve that
witness they went out and got that
witness to come testify that shows you
how out of touch they are with reality
and with the american people and why i
think as you said as clay said it's
going to be a good night for republicans
on november 8th and that means a good
night for the country and joe has a
whopping 32 percent approval rating all
right uh thank you both clay thank you
congressman thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else